Senator Marco Rubio is warning that
deadly clashes in Nicaragua could lead
to Civil War and worsen the immigration
crisis right here in the US new
protesteth protests are expected today
after thousands of people march
yesterday to demand that President
Daniel Ortega
step down the demonstrations began three
months ago over proposed benefit cuts
human rights groups say about 300 people
have been killed during these protests
many by police Manuel Bojorquez is in
the capital city of Managua Nicaragua
and well good morning good morning there
is an eerie quiet here in Managua as
people largely stay indoors and business
owners close up shop out of concern for
their own safety
but as we found when we arrived here
yesterday after the call the sounds of
protests once again pierced the air and
the fear of violent confrontations
returns within minutes of arriving in
the capital we encountered an
anti-government protest and the sound of
mortar fire with us we found several
young men masked and holding homemade
mortar launchers they told us they fire
them to warn fellow demonstrators when
pro-government forces are near you know
you're risking your lives here
so I'm up at all they're not no chap but
this is the truck the fear is gone yes
he says the fear was gone on April 19
that's the day protests started over
proposed cuts to Social Security
benefits government forces are accused
of killing more than 40 people that week
hundreds have been killed since some
even attacked while hiding in a church
the uprising continues to intensify
against President Daniel Ortega who
demonstrators say has turned into a
dictator and should step down but Ortega
remains defiant insisting the protesters
are being influenced by outside forces
and blaming them for initiating the
violence this neighborhood moaning bow
had been a stronghold of the opposition
you can see here some of the barricades
they had built using cobblestones from
the streets but there was a bloody
confrontation with police here last week
and at this point it's still unclear how
many were killed this woman feared being
identified but wanted to let us know one
thing her neighborhood was not backing
down
moaning Bull has lost the battle but not
the war mm-hmm several international
organizations have called on the
Nicaraguan government to stop the
violent suppression of protests and to
hold early elections next year but
President Daniel Ortega refuses to back
down likely setting the stage for even
more demonstrations Nora all right
Manuel thank you